last lesson we had a look at linear
modeling and the whole idea of linear
model is that loads of things loads of
practical situations in real life can
kind of be modeled demonstrated using
these linear apps okay some Sun graphs
are quite enough fer as I'll show you in
a second I want you to remember this in
fact those of you who just looked at
your arm and your task remember about
this big table and we work out how do
you calculate youth allowance okay now i
want to give you one particular example
since the people sitting in front of the
room so now it's kind of funny how
frequently that happens action please
read only a cherubic um now if you think
about youth allowance let's think about
singles under 18 living at home
unemployed okay now you don't need to
write that down all our point out is
what's the basic idea we know that up to
a certain amount I'll tell you what they
owners in a second I don't expect your
number up to a certain amount you get
our full allowance and so you're my rock
it's 143 dollars so if you are earning
money like just with a casual draw and
if you heard 143 dollars or less you get
the full out now from memory i think
that's 220 dolls and forty cents okay um
I just spend a lot of time with anything
now the interesting thing to me is what
happens after this right so all the way
from zero to hundred forty-four dollars
that's how much way in the government is
giving me but after I pass of that
threshold what happens what did they do
to this yeah you get a partial okay i
started of reduces for fifty cents per
dollar saying you ever brush
so the short answer is yes however in
order to make things a bit simpler one
of the things they haven't talked about
in the questions ribbon look here is
that this is subject to what they call a
parental income test so because you guys
are dependence right like you're getting
money like you're being like you're
where you live and the food you eat then
the utility you expend all that kind of
thing is being paid for by someone else
so they will test to see is your parents
income below a certain threshold and
then you would qualify okay that's
racial it's pretty low i should add up
until you start to become more
independent I think it's like 50 calcium
correct that's right now keep in mind at
the moment you guys have like three
education and all these other subsidies
like public transport that Allah so
that's why that's kind of built into
that concessions like it's not free yeah
okay no like I said you got a partial
out on something's right so up to now if
you if you're unemployed not a student
I'm just going to go because these
thumbs are be easier to work with um it
is 400 if you are a student a full-time
student but if you're not up to 250
you'll get a partial allowance right now
what they do is they take they start to
make the allowed smaller and smaller and
smaller by fifty cents in the doll
they reduce it by 50 cent every dollar
above that correct that's right so 144
dollars right you're earning 144 they're
going to take fifty cents off of this I
have done $45 they're going to take a
dollar off of that and on and on nine
but I've 250 they start to become a
little more aggressive they take more
money off you right so I've got 250 it's
still a partial allowance but sixty
cents is removed per dollar ok now the
numbers are not what's important here
what's important to me is that for
different parts here different rules are
kind of in operation right so now we
looked at a linear mall and it just goes
up or it just goes down out whatever
constant rain but these are not constant
rates they're changing all the time ok
and in fact after I can't remember the
no I have it I have it on this slide
than I've ever seen it's like 500 in
something ish at a certain point you're
partial else has gotten so low you just
don't get anything in yeah right no one
else no because different things are
happening at different points a simple
straight light is not enough in fact you
need something like this now I want you
to look carefully at this ok I've tried
to make it as thick as I can so that you
can see what's going on what's happening
here right I want you to look at my two
axes did you get rid of this I haven't
made my axis but you could probably name
them let me zoom
have a look at my to action is what do
you think each one represents how will
get a vote was unanimous thank you I
can't earnings are going to be one of
them a nice what about but it's not the
verdict once the horizont want to hear
my earnings right okay so this is my
earnings axis yeah and this is the
actual amount of the government's pain
okay so you can see on the allowance
access it starts up at that to twenty
and forty cents figure right and it's
just a horizontal line because
everywhere underneath this amount of
income okay in fact I withdrew if you go
draw your vertical line down we've been
doing this a lot right have a look at my
scale you can just make up these fate
lies in here that way is halfway between
not 200 there's 100 so that makes this
one 150 and there's my 143 just a little
bit before okay so what are any number
any income but 443 dollars I just keep
on getting the format so that's why it's
just flat lines like that but soon as
you hit that threshold they start taking
money off you right so you can see it in
red there it's going at fifty cents in
the dollar after you pass over another
threshold and you can see as well it's
on that line there 200-250 there's that
next threshold right if you look
carefully you can see this blue line is
just a little bit steeper than the red
line do you notice it it's steeper
because of this this number is steeper
then lastly what happens over here what
does this represent you just stop yeah
they're not paying anything anymore so
what we call this is a piecewise graph
you got different pieces of the graph
that are behaving in different ways so
i'm going to show you another one this
time i think i only the whites sir okay
definitely what okay i'll zoom in in a
second but you've got the context what's
this son these are these are piling
posts right parking costs now if i zoom
in it's not the greatest image but you
can still see enough i think it's a case
right yes it's an offer Shh what's
happening to you what's happening the
first three hours are free so i guess if
i would think about horizontal axis i'm
thinking that time time is progressing
right and vertically at the elbow how
much do I have to pay so these first
three hours hour 1 hour to hour 3 what
does the graph look like it's just flat
it's a zero right it's free
actually I would you guys grabbing the
window as well okay it's flat what
happens when you hit the first spot
after three hours you're a flat flat
flat flat flat and then now
interestingly running the graph which we
just saw which kind of went down like
that okay oops they're taking money off
okay there we go what you got here is
that there's a gap right you told me
it's going to start at in color it's
going to start at 000000 right but then
it doesn't go to like you know thirty
cents or fifty cents or a dollar or
anything in between it just straight
away it goes up to let's call that two
dollars right so there's like a junk and
there's a break in the graph but this
represents as soon you go from here to
here then I tried you a little bit
towards the left dollars then just go
straight to do dollars and then the next
thing what happens next they're doing it
in half hour increments aren't there you
can just barely see so it's going to go
up again and then again and again and so
on now because of the shape of this
graph that looks kind of like this it
looks like a set of stairs right they
call this a step graph because it
normally looks like a set of steps and
when you think about it these kinds of
things
these kinds of things they happen all
the time right they often happen with
money because it's simple that way
welcome to Sidney write that song does
he remember more square is 0 no one will
play with you it is in the city our
world square is armed it's on George
Street its authorship the poor my
cinemas are you think that's bad I went
to foon this article which I found quite
amazing what and it looks like it's a
prank except it's not if you can go
ahead you can go Google this it's on
used accommodate you it's because
they're near the CBD area so that's why
they're charging so much and you know
people would be using it and then like
convenient to work or whatever so that's
why again exactly no just just take my
car cantilever you so again you see the
steps right the different things are
happening at different points